all right good morning everybody
still just trying to get organized um
before we get started i just with our
work session i just wanted to mention
why i called it uh these bills we did
here on the late side
and i did know that there were a few of
the prime sponsors interested in
providing
some amendments
um based on what we heard at our public
public hearings
so i figured we'll take a few minutes
and at least go over them for technical
issues
if we agree that they are at least okay
to move i think we should probably still
debate the bills in our executive
session again this is just an
opportunity to talk about these
prior to in case uh we might need in
case we need another amendment uh or
well i shouldn't be too busy today i
wouldn't think
um
and i i picked these three i did mention
it with our ranking member if he hadn't
he wanted to add to the list and this is
the only three that rose to the level
so that being said
i will open the work session on
we'll start with
1447 which is
prohibiting state agencies from using
face recognition technology
i don't have any amendments to it i
looked at the language a few times i
think i'm okay with it i don't see
anything
technically wrong with it that needs to
be corrected by amendment i think we can
in my opinion debate this one way or the
other in executive session does anybody
um
the intention here is is good but i do
feel like we need to dig a little deeper
into it and i'm not sure we have that
information or if we were provided with
anything that could allow us to do that
at this point in time
so
i'm not saying i disagree with you and i
did not did not receive anything from
the prime sponsor in terms of amendment
since the hearing yeah so we can i think
pretty much discuss that in executive
session thank you okay
uh anybody else on 1447
seeing none we'll move that one aside
sorry
thank you uh this is representative
fellows and i'm on the edna committee
and i just wanted to share with you that
in 2020
my committee had a bill that was had
this in it but was also more extensive
in terms of it addressed like
how law enforcement
could
you know
how law enforcement might under some
circumstances have access to that and
also we heard issues about
how
state law enforcement sometimes need to
work with federal law enforcement and
then they have
their own rules related to this and so
just to share with you we we had several
subcommittees we had two amendments sub
two amendments proposed
and um then it all died due to covid
so
just to say it's a complicated issue and
you might need to
consider doing more work on this
thank you
thank you for that uh and again we'll
talk about the merits of the bill one
way or the other when we get to
executive session again for this work
session i'm just trying to look to see
if all our ducks in a row before we get
to that point
uh 1447 i think we're good on
okay let's go to the next one i know has
an amendment and i did pass this out to
everybody
uh we'll start with 1401
and
if representative amman would like to
explain
this amendment
just for its merits again we're going to
thank you for the opportunity to explain
this amendment mr chair
the original bill is very simple and
this amendment is also very simple
remember the recall the the intent of
the bill is to
shield new hampshire citizens from
the potential for federal mileage tax
which would be a new form of taxation
it's not a far-fetched idea the 1.2
trillion dollar infrastructure bill that
was passed contains a pilot program
for such a nationwide mileage tax
the intent of the bill is also not to
disrupt any current business of the
state or
other interested parties but to
merely shield new hampshire citizens
from this new tax
the language in in uh i don't know if
you're
is your sheet color coded
okay
and that you see green and blue both so
the language in yellow was submitted by
a company called carfax before the
original public hearing you should have
all received an email with that language
so
that language would narrow
the bill just to
third party public
authorities charged with enforcing motor
vehicle tax law
and then there was a question during the
public hearing i believe from
representative hill
how does it affect
people that lease or rent a vehicle so
that
that language in green or blue is uh to
address that issue
so happy to take any questions
no thank you for that um it seems pretty
straightforward and the only reason
again we're doing this is because i know
there were many issues brought up with
the original language
um that being said
the department of motor vehicles has
seen this amendment
and i know there were a lot of issues
with the
title bureau as well
is do you have any early opinions on
this amendment
that's it does it satisfy any of the
good morning um i am just reviewing this
um
so far i was just going to go in and
compare it to how the current the
statute reads and where this will fall
i reading this
i i don't see a problem okay
and george have anything i mean
representative psych sorry
well
so my question might be it's actually
i'm not sure that dmv is the right
person to ask but
i wonder um
this new
language of with with third-party public
authorities charged with enforcing motor
vehicle law motor vehicle tax law
without the consent of the vehicle's
owner
shouldn't we hear from someone who is
responsible for collecting taxes to see
how they
would view that because it sounds to me
like well i don't want to debate it now
but that's i just wonder if
it raises as many questions
as it tries to answer
yeah no
fair enough and again i'm not trying to
force any issues here i'm just giving
these prime sponsors an opportunity to
modify this with the short amount of
time we have
that's a good point
yep representative i guess i have a
question just if either you can clarify
it or someone else um
there was concerns about the truth and
mileage act
and um being able to
ensure that odometers are not tampered
with that kind of thing is there i don't
know if this addresses any of those
issues
it attempts to with the with that
highlighted language with third-party
public authorities i mean i i think we
can all understand what the prime
sponsor's trying to do with this is just
put up a firewall from any additional
taxes coming from the federal government
it's prohibiting that that's causing
issues with other things okay that line
attempts to do it um i guess that's what
we do here today to see if it
accomplishes that or not and that's why
i'm doing this now to see what the
opinions are with all the stakeholders
anybody else on this and we can
further discuss this at our executive
session
and i'll talk with the prime sponsor in
a moment
on
what to do next
thank you just wanted to point out uh
the language doesn't prohibit
an authority to tax a vehicle
it just does so
on the basis of mileage
so
if you can tax a vehicle without needing
the mileage information you can still do
that so
you know the way towns and
cities do it so thank you
thank you
all right we'll chat in a few minutes uh
because if we're gonna if you would like
the committee to entertain this
obviously we'll have to get to ols and
and get an official draft
uh last one i put on the work session uh
is
thank you mr chairman
uh so and thank you for setting up the
conversation with deputy director mike
todd of the registry motor vehicles um
in discussing with him he explained some
of the
issues that the registry saw with the
original bill
and one of the biggest ones was they
have no infrastructure for sending out
fines apparently fines by mail is not a
thing that anyone except the easy pass
people really do
and so their primary way of issuing
citations or fines is
an in-person interaction with a police
officer at a traffic stop or something
else similar to that
so what this amendment does is that
takes out
any concept of fines and also as was
pointed out in the public hearing there
is already a fine established for
violation of this section on the
universal fine schedule
so it doesn't change that universal fine
schedule stays as it was it takes out
the monthly fines that would have to be
sent by mail and just creates a new
requirement that an individual
who
registered to vote here
same-day same-day registered vote here
presented an out-of-state driver's
license
with that their information would then
go over to the rmv
and they'd be able to tell if they
didn't comply with this section to
either
transfer that driver's license to an
in-state one or file a new form
explaining why and then
the theorized acceptable reasons why or
either they moved back out of state or
they gave up their driving privilege
this would also create uh direct the
registry motor vehicles to send notices
which director todd said they do all the
time they do have the capability to send
notices
for anyone that was more than 30 days
overdue
filing
either transferring their license or
filing that form
so they'd be informed
and coming out of the voter registration
database they should have both an
in-state address and an out-of-state
address the out-of-state address is
whatever was associated with their
driver's license which the secretary of
state already records into this database
the jurisdiction of issuance and the
driver's license number
and the in-state address should be their
voting domicile which is already in that
database as well
so they'll get a notice that they
haven't done it if they do it that's
fine they're off the naughty list if
they don't do it we we have that we'll
have that list in the registry mode of
vehicles people that have
voted here not transferred driver's
license and not explained why
which was the original core intent of
the bill was to make sure that we narrow
that category down
um did you have conversations with the
secretary of state's office as well yes
uh his biggest concern was that he
didn't want to be in a discretionary
role the original bill said apparent
violation and he didn't want to be in
the role of judging what a violation is
or isn't he just wants to provide
information
representative
uh thank you mr chairman representative
prout thank you for taking this question
so
how does this amendment change i'm
i've missed where you've changed
something so that the secretary of
state's office's concern is answered
so his biggest concern in the
information provision was that the
original bill said he should provide any
information on apparent violations of
rsaid all right 263-35 he didn't want to
be in the position of judging what an
apparent violation was or wasn't
i can't follow up
yeah
i follow that what i'm asking you is
where in your amendment did you answer
his concern
so in the new subparagraph 2
um
that he'll he'll
provide records without a state driver's
license information where the record
cannot be matched to an in-state
driver's license obtained within the
deadline provided thank you i just
yep and and he won't judge whether it's
a violation of 235 just
if it doesn't meet those fixed
parameters he'll provide the information
over the registry and the registry and
motor vehicles will be the one judging
whether
the notice
the new notice provided in
paragraph b or c on in section one has
been provided whether the timelines were
met or anything else of that nature
thank
you any other thoughts from anybody on
excuse me um
thank you for being here this morning uh
representative prout do you have any
idea
how how prolific this problem is
i mean do we have a
something from the secretary of state
that says
x number of people presented a out of
state driver's license in order to
register to vote
thank you for the question at the public
hearing i handed out to the committee
the 2017 report
that was a joint report from the
commissioner safety and the secretary of
state analyzing the 2016 general
election
and i don't have a copy with me it's
probably my bag but there was just shy
of 6000 i believe individuals who
had same day registered a vote
with that same day registration
presented an out of state driver's
license and then i believe the report
was run some 10 months after the
election and at that 10 month mark
just shy of um i think it was 6 500 had
same day registered and just shy of 6
000 had still not transferred the
driver's license
okay
thank you very much
representative hill
thank you
i'll add to that that i was involved
with a um
an evaluation of
different
voting districts
and
i'll just bring up manchester for
instance there were
two of the 12 wards i think there's 12
wards
there were
three wards that
that took the information that um he's
speaking about from the secretary of
state there were three awards that
actually wrote down
um
which is the requirement wrote down the
state that the outer state driver's
license was from
three wards did that the other awards
indicated that there were none
that not a single person came in and and
wrote down
and used an out-of-state driver's
license so it's not
a perfect science i guess is my point
they are
some places do it some places don't do
it so that's all i wanted to add
just to clarify if i mail i think if i
may i think you're talking about
existing voters already on the checklist
they're supposed to note when they when
they sign in but there's also i believe
a separate longer form for if you're
registering as a brand new voter
uh that's correct but when you register
as a as a brand new voter
you're taking that sheet and then they
write it in on the on the checklist and
they're supposed to indicate at that
point what driver's license was used
and and only as i said three out of the
wards in manchester were actually doing
it so i'm not
it's it's not a perfect number that
you're that you're throwing out it's
it's
under reported if anything
thank you
andy representative
um looking at
page 1 line 20
it says the director for good cause
shown may grant an extension of a
deadline
i have a problem that it doesn't say an
exception
as we discussed at the hearing there are
situations where someone might move here
and
become a non-driver or or
move here and and not
change their driver's license because
they're not a driver maybe a senior
citizen or something like that
and you just said that the director can
understand why
it has the information has been filed
don't you think there are some
exceptions
and is there any
sorry i'm just thinking this language
doesn't address that concern of mine
thank you for the question um
the situation raised really should fall
under paragraph c on line 14 on that
page
um
is my thinking that if they've you know
given up their driving privilege and and
either relinquished or uh their driver's
license in their you know original issue
state
they can file the form and say that and
then they that should take care of that
um to the point where whether someone
can keep their driver's license from the
state they moved from
after becoming a new hampshire resident
and just not drive here um
i don't see how that's allowed in the
existing language and paragraph that one
and now being moved into paragraph a
i thought i heard that the public
hearing that someone said that as long
as you never get behind the wheel of a
car in new hampshire this doesn't apply
and i
don't know
why the person that said that thought
that was a true statement because at
least as i
am able to view everything i don't
believe it is a true statement can i
inquire well because someone might move
here
and
their lifestyle may change and they may
not be a driver so it that they're not
being forced to get a driver's license
here in new hampshire you could have an
onset of a medical condition you can be
a senior citizen moving to be near their
family there's a lot of reasons why
someone would move here and not need to
get a new valid driver's license if
and i'm seeing sorry i'm just seeing
someone from the dmv agree
nodding their head that there are
situations so i guess there are
exceptions
thank you and like i said i thought that
was covered by paragraph c where as long
as they you know notify their former
state that i don't want my driver's
license anymore then they just file the
form contemplated in paragraph c
all handled
let's uh well i'm going to ask the
department of motor vehicles next maybe
she can address it is there anything
else from
seeing none why don't i do this then uh
anybody from either the department of
motor vehicles or department of safety
i
would like to chime in on any
good morning
okay so um i saw this amendment uh
yesterday afternoon and kind of
responded back i know he's had
communications with deputy director todd
and i'm not sure if mr
todd has seen some of the items that i
wanted to highlight back in regards to
proposed language
i'm certainly open to continue
conversations with the representative on
this
the administration of this and
understanding at what point does a
person become a resident is it when they
sign their lease documents so when they
walk into motor vehicles and we see that
they sign their lease document and say
june but they're not coming to us until
that october point we still issue them a
license we don't stop them we don't
prevent them but at that point would it
be the expectation that we would be
stopping and being like timeout um
you're over your 60-day window
we do not have the authority to issue
suspensions or citations and that would
be on law enforcement i think some of
the conversation i was hearing
was roadside so if you're in a community
and there is an officer that's aware
that you've overstayed that 60-day mark
and you're still on your out-of-state
place you're still on your out-of-state
registration you know they could be
cited for that currently as it is under
statute
um
just some of the notes that i had tossed
back to
the deputy director that
you know is this going to be through the
issuance of a citation
what about individuals who can register
a vehicle within the state of new
hampshire if they own property but you
do not have to obtain a new hampshire
license and i'm not sure if that was the
intent of 260 144 but that was more of a
reciprocity and i read that as a person
that can drive their vehicle in new
hampshire with their out-of-state plates
so what documents again would we be
looking at generally for law enforcement
and or the motor vehicles in regards to
the residency status at what point is
that that bona fide residency is it
through the actual establishment with
the town when they go that day to
register their vehicle or is it that day
when they come into motor vehicles
the form that
is contemplated within the proposed
language what is the expectation of dmv
when we get that do we need to be
reaching back
to these other jurisdictions saying hey
we just want to let you know that
there's a person here they haven't
obtained a license but they've been in
our state for this period of time um
again
how's that exchange of information going
to happen and what are the expectations
for
a paragraph be one of my concerns is
what constitutes ceasing to be a
resident at what point does a person
decide that they don't want to be
a resident like is there a hard date
they said on the state i'm no longer a
resident and then wait for them to
vacate are they in the transition of
moving
do they have loose ends that they're
tying up before they can get back to
for paragraph c
relinquished after becoming a resident
of the state does this mean obtaining a
new hampshire license to which that kind
of already meets 263 35 as we're talking
about if you're really positioning your
license is it are you
not renewing your license in the state
because i think it contemplates the
expiration of the license but then
relinquishing what is the difference um
just kind of understanding what that
the director shall notify an individual
that there appears to be they appear to
be in violation appears to be is
subjective
would we be taking the facts provided to
us in law enforcement again is this a
director's complaint there's just a lot
of things i think we would have to
figure out the administration of this
okay did you just say you would have to
figure it out or is is it figure out
able
i mean because i was first going to say
it sounds like you're still going to
laugh a lot of questions but then your
last statement said that doesn't mean we
can't do it
we still have a lot of questions on what
this all means
okay um
again
i think i've got the point uh
representative
thank you miss shoot um i'm curious
there's two two groups of people we
haven't discussed and i'm not quite sure
that we dealt with it at the public
hearing either which was
people who hold a non-driver
identification card and use that to vote
how
this would affect them
and
military who are here and stationed but
vote locally i'm curious how this would
thank you
may the witness is nodding yes
yes does that mean all of that so do you
okay
all right
um with anything else anybody else from
the committee
uh you it or not uh that's
pretty much all i wanted to accomplish
with this work session is just to have a
quick discussion over what we have in
front of us
albeit i know these bills are were heard
late and our deadlines are fast
approaching
so with that
seeing nothing else from the committee
we have the information again i'll talk
to the prime sponsors in a couple of
minutes
in terms of what the rest of our day is
going to look like 9 35
again that's what i wanted to accomplish
in this i do have our executive session
scheduled for 10.
i figured we'd have a
we can take a break and have our
respective
meetings or caucuses whatever you'd like
to call them
and then get into our
executive sessions
uh it's actually i'm trying believe it
or not it may not sound it but i've been
thinking about this for a week trying to
make sure this is organized as possible
and that's the reason for this workshop
so that when we get to exec session
it's my hopes that things go as smoothly
as possible
i guess we'll go have a meeting across
um
we're going to go across the hub you can
stay
all right so we shall we shall return
we're going to caucus
we shall return i came through
and
all right welcome everybody sorry for
a couple things before we do get started
just trying to get as organized as
possible i know we have a lot of bills
to execute today it is the balance of
our bills
and so hopefully that organization will
help us move through our executive
sessions pretty smooth
the other thing i've been pretty
generous on reports
but facing our deadlines i'm going to
need all the reports from committee
members that make those motions before
we leave today whether they're on my
laptop or in hard copy matters not to me
but
i don't have time to to wait for them
after this
session
i did have an order
that i put in not with for any
particular reason and i'm not
necessarily going to take them up in
that order either i know we're waiting
on possible amendments
on a couple
so
um
i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1341.
it's a definition of conviction
the chair recognizes representative hill
is there a second thank you second by
representative gagne uh any thoughts
representative hill
uh thank you mr chairman i'm looking up
the bill
sorry to catch you guys yeah i was
waiting for the 1401 bill to come
through
um
oh this uh this i think can be deemed as
it simply is crossing out uh for the
purposes of rsa 264 a forfeiture
a bail or collateral deposited to secure
an appearance in court
and for the purposes of commercial
driver's license statutes
it appears to be
something that the department had asked
us to
to clarify and
and it's a very simple build thank you
thank you for that anybody else from the
committee
seeing none
what representative hill said is correct
i introduced this
for the department of motor vehicles it
is a housekeeping bill and something
important to them
with nothing else from the committee a
motion on the floor is ought to pass
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll when
she's ready
vice chairman gagne
yes representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill
yes representative thompson
yes representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative torrenson
yes representative sykes
yes representative fellows yes
representative fenton
representative rambo yes
representative rich
representative talaski yes
representative fox
yes representative stevens yes
representative woods yes
chairman walsh yes
yes
19-0
okay the committee recommendation of
ought to pass 19-0
i saw representative hill was there a
second to the other hand representative
without objections consent that it's
that'll close the executive session on
house bill 1341 give us a few moments to
reset
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1302
relative to the weighing of vehicles
chair recognizes representative smith
for a motion thank you mr chair i move
out to pass on house bill 1302
motions out to pass is there a second
seconded by representative hill
care to speak to your motion
sure thank you mr chair
the um i believe the statute was
probably always meant to apply to
commercial vehicles
this bill would
prevent you from being ordered by a law
enforcement officer to drive your
personal vehicle not a commercial
vehicle
10 miles to a scale or submit to a
roadside way
most of the people that are being cited
for problems right now are getting
tagged other ways the scrap guys
unsecured or unsafe load
driving erratically because the vehicle
is overloaded there's a lot of ways to
do it and they can look at it by sight
they already have probable cause to pull
you over because of this so i don't
think the bill has any impact on what's
going on other than you can't be ordered
to drive 10 miles to a scale you get a
different ticket
thank you
uh further discussion
representative sykes
yeah thank you mr chairman so
um the the part that causes me
gives me pause is the fact that one the
department of safety was opposed to this
bill
two
in in my opinion it is a
solution looking for a problem
because it's it just doesn't seem to be
that big of a problem and
i think that
i don't i think it's a bill that's not
necessary
discussion seeing none i'll ask the
clerk to call the roll when she's ready
the motion is ought to pass
uh vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative torrenson yes
representative sykes no
representative fellows no
representative fenton
representative rambo no
representative rich
no
representative talersky no
representative fox no representative
stevens
no representative woods no
okay
ten to nine
chairman oh sorry oh i'm sorry
chairman walsh yes
now it's time
sorry
a committee recommendation about to pass
has adopted 10 to 9.
obviously this is not going on consent
and i never would have guessed in a
million years uh that this would go on
the regular calendar
that will close the executive session on
house bill
130 well two did is there a minority
report
okay
i just let representative gagne know
when you know i'll close the executive
you
all right i'm going to open up the
executive session on house bill 1562.
clarifying the prohibition on using an
electronic or telecommunications device
while driving chair recognizes
mr chairman i move out the pass on 1562.
motions ought to pass is there a second
second
seconded by representative hill
uh would you care to speak to a motion
thank you
this changes the
uh the rsa
it's what it is it's a
housekeeping
using a different rsa instead of the
original rsa which
the original rsa kind of prohibited
people from using bluetooth when they
were driving
they were in violation so this
rsa
brings in conformity that
people who are driving on the highway
can use bluetooth to communicate
but because it's a hands-free thing so
this just cleans it up
thank you
any further discussion
representative sykes
yeah i would be in support of this
motion it's a little bit of housekeeping
as called that needed to be done it
clarifies some of the
minor points of this uh differences
between
an old texting while driving bill
law versus the hands-free law
and
so it's a step in the right direction to
making hands-free convictions in court a
little bit better and easier
and and i do concur uh just for history
this bill did pass last year went on
consent um
it demise was in the senate when they
piled on a bunch of amendments uh
hopefully that doesn't happen this time
um with nothing else from the committee
i'll ask the clerk to call the role when
she's ready the motion is ought to pass
vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith yes clerk votes yes
representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative torreson yes
representative sykes yes
representative fellows yes
representative fenton yes
representative rambo yes representative
rich
yes representative talorsky
yeah representative fox
yes representative stevens yes
representative woods yes chairman walsh
yes
19-0
okay committee recommendation about the
pass is adopted 19-0
motion
for consent
that was made and seconded
without objection consent that'll go
i'll close the
1447. i
i just got the amendment for 1534 that
i've been patiently well waiting for
and i'm not sure it does what i need it
to do so i want to decide where we're
going to head with that
um
yes
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session
just for the title yep
so i don't keep flipping through the
pages here
on house bill
1447 prohibiting state agencies from
using face recognition technology
uh chair recognizes representative gagne
for a motion
thank you mr chairman i would move
interim study
on house bill 1447.
trump study is the motion do i hear a
second
second second by representative thompson
any thoughts on your motion
representative agne uh very simply um
i don't really understand what this bill
is going to do i think it has
more questions than answers
for one thing there's no list of
exceptions
i think it's it needs work
there is some merit to it so i believe
interim study
real interim study could come up with
some solutions that would be amenable to
all parties concerned
fair enough
any further discussion from the
committee representative sykes
thank you mr chairman
um
i think it's important to note that
there are some important stakeholders
like the department of safety or the
aclu and others and they have opposing
positions as far as what what should be
done with this issue
and so i agree with uh
vice chairman gagne that this bill
raises
as many questions as it may answer and
so interim study would be an appropriate
course of
action fair enough thank you sir any
further discussion from the committee
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready the motion on
the floor is interim study on house bill
1447.
vice chairman uh gagney
yes
representative smith yes clerk beauties
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative ankerberg
yes representative gorski yes
representative boyd yes representative
morrison yes representative sykes yes
representative fellows yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo yes representative rich yes
representative talarsky yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative woods yes
chairman walsh
yes
committee recommendation of interim
motion for consent was made by
representative gagne
seconded by representative hill without
objections
consent that is i'll close the
executive session on house bill 1447.
uh we'll take up
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1474
relative to annual vehicle inspections
chair recognizes representative smith
for a motion thank you mr chair and move
out to pass in house bill 1474.
motion is out to pass is there a second
second seconded by representative gagne
do you care to speak to motion
yes thank you mr chair um
so what this does is it supports all the
arguments that we've heard over the
years that a vehicle should be seen once
a year
to get critical safety components
checked brakes wheel bearings ball
joints etc and a lot of that you're not
going to check yourself
the problem that it solves is
right now
if you buy a car that is a few months
away but beyond the window that we have
to get inspected it isn't being seen
once a year
also low-income people they get hit with
a hundred couple of hundred bucks for
registration and immediately might also
be on the hook for a few hundred dollars
for repairs if they choose to
they can separate those events
by getting their car inspected in a
different month in their registration
their birthday's in december maybe they
want to do all that in june and have six
months between those bills it gives
people flexibility if they like it the
way it is now you don't have to do
anything different there's no safety
impact
and it gives people the flexibility and
the cars are still seen every year there
was a little talk in the hearing about
confusion while the sticker's going to
match not match the registration anymore
right nothing to be confused about the
point is it doesn't matter the bottom
line on the bill is the stick is either
good or it's not that's not confusing
thank you mr chair
thank you any further discussions from
the committee
representative sykes
so um
the argument that took hold for me was
the one about economics for low-income
persons being challenged by this by the
current state of affairs for inspections
and registration
with that in mind i personally am going
representative tolerski thank you mr
reiterate that this would just be an
option for someone not forced upon
anyone so the number of people that
actually take advantage of this i think
are somewhat slim but those who could
take advantage of it
i think it would uh it's primarily
people who do have older vehicles that
may require
more extensive safety repairs
so i think that's a good thing and
while i respect and understand
the testimony from the department of
safety that
it would be a new thing and hard to
educate i think
uh change can be sometimes a little bit
of a challenge but it doesn't
necessarily mean it's bad so i will be
supporting the all to pass also
thank you very much any other
discussion a question there and i
apologize
thank you i just like clarification
because
um
when i look at this it appears that
currently
you can get your vehicle inspected four
months before
your the month of your birth
and that's crossed out it's so now is it
moved to four months after instead of
four months before or do you have both
options
let me get to it unless representative
sure thing
it's
yeah because right now there's actually
a window
of 30 days because of the way the
statutes are worded where you might be
able to get a more than 12 month
registration but not an inspection i
can't remember works vice versa
this simplifies it whenever you choose
to go get your car inspected it's 12
months from then so the window's no
longer necessary
and that only occurs on your very first
registration anyway that window
follow-up so
can you
just
what i'd currently do is i get my my car
inspected
usually not in my birth month
usually two you know um one or two
months earlier than that does this
negate my option to do that
no
no this is really all about flexibility
seeing none
uh last clerk to call the roll when
she's ready the
vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative torreson yes
representative sykes
yes representative fellows yes
representative fenton
representative
rambo
rambo sorry yes
representative rich
yes representative
yes representative fox
yes representative stevens yes
representative woods yes chairman walsh
yes
uh committee recommendation about to
move consent by representative fenton is
there a second representative gagne
uh without objection consent that is
i'll close the executive session on
house bill 1474.
uh give us a few moments
we'll take up 14 26
next
ted
i got it now
all right i'm going to open up the
executive session on house bill 1426
eliminating the vehicle inspection
mandate for non-commercial vehicles
uh chair recognizes representative
gorsky for a motion
thank you mr chair i move to itl
uh house bill 1426. motions itl is there
a second second second by representative
gagne would you care to speak your
motion i will thank you mr chairman
um
you know vehicle
inspections i think are very important
here in our state to make sure that as a
driver that we know that there are
fellow cars on the road that are safe to
drive
we had testimony
from
many people who mentioned that
part of the vehicle inspection has
caused found some rust issues on frame
of vehicles i know recently i brought i
bring my brought mine in
and it was discovered that there was
rust and i'm a person that brings it
brings my car in religiously to get
repaired so it catches those small
little things and i think that's
something real important that we need to
sustain in this
in our state so i
again vote for itl on hb 1426 thank you
thank you any further discussion from
the committee
representative sykes
so um thank you mr chairman so i would
echo the comments from my learned
colleague uh
recently made
about uh inspections they're an
important component of the
good safety record that this state has
but like all safety records this can it
can always be improved and so i do not
see this bill as being something that
improves our safety record and therefore
any further discussion from the
committee
i'll just say this on it
we see this bill quite often in
transportation
i'm a firm believer in the program that
we have
but it doesn't mean that some of the
issues that other people present are not
going unheard or are going unheard
i've already started the discussion for
maybe addressing some of those for next
year maybe looking at some of the
predatory stations that we may have not
saying we do
it's actually a national issue um and
also looking at the actual rules that
cause a vehicle to fail
i know we addressed rust or cosmetic
rust a few years ago and said
that's not a safety issue that shouldn't
fail a vehicle
i'm trying to do one with exhaust
systems i mean you can go down the list
of a lot of things that currently are
failing vehicles that perhaps shouldn't
because they don't have to
address
safety because they don't address safety
so
i'm going to support the itl today but
it doesn't mean that the conversations
about how to make this program better in
the future
won't continue so
with that being said uh the motion on
the floor is itl on house bill 1426.
uh i'll ask the clerk to call the rule
when she's ready
vice chairman gagne yes representative
smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative torrenson
did he leave
representative sykes
yes
representative fellows yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo yes representative rich yes
representative talaski
yes representative fox yes
representative stevens yes
representative woods yes chairman walsh
yes
18 to
zero 18 18
okay the committee recommendation of itl
and hospital 1426 is adopted 18-0
um
okay
motion motion to consent and i saw a
second a motion for consent and yet
without objection uh consent that will
go
with that being said i'll close the
executive session on
i'm going to move things around only
because i have an issue with an
amendment
and we are going to end up doing a few
more three more than probably taking a
recess
a short one
before we resume
and we have plenty of time uh so give us
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session
on
house bill 1643 we're modifying a new
resident driver's license transfer
requirement
chair recognizes representative
crawford for a motion
thank you mr chairman i make the motion
ocean's interim study dwight ii
seconded by representative hill
we care to speak to your motion
i believe that there's still a lot of
confusion in this bill and a lot of
questions that we have
so that i think the best avenue is to
have an interim study to answer some of
those questions
further discussion from the committee
representation
thank you mr chair
um i agree as well there may be some
things we need to look at on this bill
but uh for the most part i think it's
the uh the concept is a good one and i
hope that when it gets
into the committee that
they can find solutions to bring back
another bill that we can pass
out of this committee thank you
fair enough thank you any other
discussion
representative
thank you mr chairman
um
while i can support interim study
i feel that uh as we have worked through
this bill it seems like
there just continues to be more flags
and problems that have come up with it
so
i will support it although i think that
it potentially
is looking to apply motor vehicle law in
such a way to people who aren't actually
drivers
and i hope that we can figure out a way
to make sure that we aren't
unnecessarily
imposing violations on those
that uh
should not be getting them but i thank
you
um i will agree that was one of the
issues raised i do see the merit in this
um
i'll take some responsibility of it i've
scheduled this late not not knowing
and unfortunately now we are looking at
deadlines with all the questions that
were still there
uh this is a legitimate interim study i
am interested in seeing this move
forward i just can't support it at this
time we still have a lot of questions
remaining
uh that being said i'll ask the clerk to
call the role whenever she's ready the
motion on the floor is interim study
vice chairman gagne
yes representative smith yes clerk
poltias representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative torreson yes
representative sykes yes representative
fellows yes representative fenton yes
representative rambo yes representative
rich yes representative toloroski yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative woods yes
chairman walsh yes
19-0
committee recommendation of interim
study and house bill 1643 is adopted
19-0
consent's been moved by representative
gagner is there a second by
representative thompson
without objection consent that is
i'll close the executive session on
house bill 1643
a few moments and we'll take up house
all right i'll open up the executive
session on house bill
1570.
relative to reducing vehicle
registration fees
the chair recognizes representative
ankerberg for a motion thank you mr
chairman i move uh inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1570. motion is
itl is there a second
second
representative hill seconds would you
care to speak to your motion
yes thank you mr chairman um
according to the municipal association a
conservative estimate the impact of this
bill would be
82 and a half million dollar per year
reduction in revenue upwards of 90
million per year statewide and while i
am in favor of cutting fees
and other associated expenses that's a
bridge too
far thank you sir any other discussion
seeing none
uh
motion is
itl on house bill 1570 i'll ask the
clerk to call the rule when she's ready
vice chairman gagney yes
representative smith yes clerk voties
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative ankerberg
yes representative gorski yes
representative
boyd yes
representative torrenson yes
representative sykes yes representative
fellows yes representative fenton
representative rambo yes representative
rich yes representative tolorski yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative woods yes
chairman walsh
yes
committee recommendation of ito on house
bill 1570 is adopted 19-0
representatives consent is there a
second
second by representative ankerberg with
any with no objection
consent it is i'll close the executive
session on house bill 1570.
i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1424 relative to
the speed limit for watercraft on lake
winnipesaukee
che recognizes representative sykes for
a motion nope it's crawford
crawford i didn't make my correction
chad recognizes representative crawford
for a motion
thank you mr chairman
my motion is to itl 1424.
motion is itl is there a second second
would you care to speak to your motion
yes i do
so
this was um an interesting bill that we
we as a committee received hundreds i
mean when i say hundreds i mean hundreds
of emails
myself personally because i live in the
town of moultonborough and we actually
own the largest section of lake
winnipesaukee
it's a safety issue as far as i'm
concerned personally and as far as my
constituents are concerned and i felt
that
eliminating the speed limit on
winnipesaukee whether it be in the
broads or not is a hazard to all those
who participate and
in recreation on the lake and therefore
i
any further discussion
representative sykes
so i also
can and do support the itl motion
nothing in all of the testimony that we
heard
give gave me any concrete data supported
decision to not keep the speed limit
which is a public safety issue it's the
prime directive of this of
transportation amongst others of course
to promote public safety and this this
bill would not do so so an itl motion is
appropriate
further discussion
representative thank you mr chairman um
i too will support the itl from the
various testimony from as my esteemed
colleague mentioned
but
more importantly what i'm more concerned
with is i appreciate the
responsible boat owners who might be
able to navigate this what i'm more
concerned with is the irresponsible ones
that if that kind of happens it can
cause some issues and because of that i
further discussion
thank you mr chairman um
as one of the unfortunate co-sponsors of
this bill
early on i thought it wasn't a bad idea
after the response that i've gotten
well over 800 emails the majority of
those the vast majority against the bill
i'm going to
thank you
any further discussion from the
committee representative ankerberg thank
you mr chairman never afraid to take an
unpopular position i will note that
during the online hearing 601
signed in remotely to support the the
bill while only 206 opposed we also
heard that marine patrol takes no
position on this bill
seeing fit to allow the boating
community itself to
sort of self adjudicate how they would
uh
wish um to be regulated
um
with that given i will not support the
itl and i would hope that we would give
more thought to this given that this
committee in the past
has rejected um
body specific
legislation
and where this is a state resource we
really should be acting in a uniform
manner across all different lakes and
ponds thank you
further discussion
thank you for representing sorry thank
you
in the last century having been a
helmsman
from time to time on a 360-foot
destroyer
going through the atlantic there was no
problem
going through the mediterranean things
got a little dicey
then the aegean sea loaded with islands
you really had to slow down and watch
what the hell you were doing because
people were going all over the place
going through the suez canal and into
the red sea things even got even
narrower even though the red sea is
relatively wide
so i
a boat does not stop on a dime
and
i remember one time we had to stop an
emergency this little probably a
20-footer fishing boat in the red sea
was a dao or whatever they were they
were called with a big sail we're right
in our path
we saw it maybe
three quarters of a mile away by the
time we stopped it was only about 300
yards from us
so i would say
that
speed kills
and
i've i've been to lake winnipesaukee and
even though there are no speed limits on
other on other lakes i think the needs
of the many outweigh the needs of the
few
and that's why i'll be voting itl on
well i'll chime in on this
i knew you would um i've been navigating
lake winnipesaukee for decades
i was opposed to the speed limit when it
was imposed made with 13 years ago for
the same reasons my colleague listed a
few minutes ago i couldn't have said it
better myself
just a couple of other thoughts on it i
heard that this was somehow by lifting
the speed limit we would be putting
safety at jeopardy
i don't see that i think if this was
going to be a safety issue that the
marine patrol certainly would have
weighed in on it and they did not
um
in terms of traffic on the lake yeah it
can be busy on the weekends and like
every other speed limit these are these
are recommendations you can go slower if
it's busy we are expected to do the same
thing on the roads
if we have an issue with unqualified
boaters maybe we should be looking at
that we'll be talking about something
may help with that this afternoon
but in the meantime i didn't see any
data that showed
at all that that eliminating the daytime
speed limit was going to be a detriment
to safety so for that and principle
i am going to oppose
the itil
that being said i'll ask the chair to
call the rule when she's ready the
motion on the floor is she gave me a
promotion
i-t-l oh sorry clerk
thank you
vice chairman cagney
yes
representative smith
no
clerk votes yes representative kell yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg no
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative torrenson i
think he's derozan
representative sykes
yes
representative fellows yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo yes representative rich
yes representative
yes representative fox
yes representative stevens
yes representative woods yes
committee recommendation of itl on house
bill 1424 is adopted 15 to 3.
i guess this is regular calendar
with that i'll close
the executive session on house bill 14
24.
is there gonna be a minority report yeah
that's why you're just gonna ask
um
i i'm not sure yet we'll figure it out
it has to be in by this afternoon at uh
four o'clock there's going to be a
menard is there
he still loves you is there no it
doesn't
there will be a minority reporter in
all right at this time we're going to go
into recess with the executive session
um
we may be able to get a few more in i'm
all right folks slight change of plans
just to keep it official i'm going to
open up the executive session on house
bill 1463
and i'm going to close or go into recess
i should say
uh our executive session on the
remainder of these bills until after our
public hearing on senate bill 307 this
afternoon a couple of things came up i
need to take care of we'll take care of
okay being 107. i'm going to open up the
public hearing on senate bill 307
and the chair recognizes senator ward
prime sponsor
welcome
good afternoon chairman walsh and the
members of the committee
for the record my name is senator ruth
ward representing senate district 8
and i'm pleased to introduce senate bill
307 relative to the issuance of safe
boater education certificates
as you may recall during the governor's
state of emergency in 2020 many new
hampshire programs were moved to an
online platform including the safe
boater education exam
emergency order number order 29 which i
exhibit one was signed by the governor
on may 22 2020 and provided that a safe
voter education course written test be
administered by a proctor or other
person approved to offer boating safety
courses shall be satisfied by any
applicant achieving a score of at least
90 percent on an online boating safety
course written test that is not
proctored or administered by an
instructor
this emergency order was in effect until
july 1 2021 when the state of emergency
expired
this bill would modify new hampshire
safe border education statute to allow
for the exam to be taken via an online
platform consistent with the emergency
order
we saw record numbers of future voters
taking the exam when this option was
provided and i believe this legislation
will continue to allow access to the
exam that may not be otherwise attained
governor sununu indicated last year that
there were numerous emergency orders
that could be put into law and i
strongly believe that this is one
part of the bill is also
the the bill also exempt certain
commercial driver instructors from
licensing requirements so long as they
meet federal standards
thank you for your consideration and i
ask the committee to vote or to pass on
thank you
will you take any questions
any questions from the committee
next up chair recognizes gary abbott
associated general contractors in
thank you chairman committee members for
the record my name's gary abbott i'm the
executive vice president of the
associated general contractors
of new hampshire
i'm here today in support of senate bill
as amended by the senate
i'm here for the part that was amended
which was the
cdl licenses
it was a
i can tell you
that
caught us a little bit by surprise in
december
but there's a whole new training
requirement that was put on on the
federal level
and we needed to update the current
statutes within our state law
regarding the cdl licenses
to make sure we can conform to the new
requirements for trainer education
they put in some requirements for
trainers to be
registered online
as well as
they outlined how many hours and what
training needed to take place maybe not
how many hours but what training things
you need to cover
and there were also
classroom training as well as driver
training and it all went into effect
february 7th
the federal agency that put this in
did give a waiver for the state of new
hampshire to catch up its laws for 90
days that waiver was provided back in
january
this what this legislation does is it
corrects our statute so we can utilize
this training
i represent a number of contractors that
have lots of trucks they need cdl
drivers some of them do some of this
training
so with that there's also a public
component for people to get trained for
smaller
contractors and truckers and
the rest so
we're here today in support of this
legislation because we need it to be
passed within the time frame of the 90
days
to meet the federal requirement and have
it comply
now i'm not the expert at the language
that was produced the department of
safety
deputy commissioner richard bailey is
probably the key guy that worked on this
so i want to give him a lot of credit in
the department of safety
with connections with the attorney
general's office but i'm one of the
associations that has truckers
we've already put out a lot of materials
to our members on how to conform to this
new regulation
it you know
you have to step back and say hey
what the federal government had worked
on for two years i guess it was in the
making for two years just wasn't aware
of that when they rolled it out was
somewhat of a surprise
but it's good for our industry to make
sure there's proper training of those
people driving our trucks and cdls so i
think everything that's there
we've had a number of meetings with all
of the appropriate agencies and it's
been very productive to help us make
sure we can conform to those new
requirements so i'm sure you're going to
hear from the department of safety that
they require this in order for somebody
to newly get a cdl license
so i'm totally here in support of this
bill so that you can
pass it as soon as possible so that way
we conform with our statutes to what the
feds have put in place
and appreciate your support for this
bill on senate bill 307
thank you any questions from the
committee
i have a question of the chair um
chairman walsh will we be hearing from
either the dmv or the department of
safety
yes okay that'll save my questions for
them thank you
thank you very much
uh
looking like for to be the original bill
not the amendment
representing cal comey
good afternoon
i'm steven bristow vice president for
government affairs at kawakamai
enterprises and i'm here to testify
today in support of senate bill 307
we're a texas-based company and our
mission is to create outdoor enthusiasts
to do that we partner with state
agencies such as the new hampshire state
police to provide online voter education
to fulfill our mission we partner with
agencies in all 50 states as well as the
canadian provinces to provide online
education courses here in the great
state of new hampshire we work with the
new hampshire state police to provide
online voter education as well as the
fish and game department for hunter
education and an all-terrain vehicle
snowmobile rider education department
as senator ward mentioned during the new
hampshire state of emergency governor
sununu issued an emergency order
enabling students to complete their
boating education exams online to give
you an example of that 38
547 students completed their courses
through our online
exam and did it with an average score of
a 94 correct
since the emergency order expired
students have been able to complete our
course but have had to go back to taking
their their final exam through an online
or through a project exam in person
we appreciate senator ward sponsoring
this important legislation to provide
another tool for new hampshire residents
to move forward with completing their
exams online again we look forward to
continuing to work with senior award as
this
legislation goes through the process we
also look forward to continuing work
with captain dunleavy who we've enjoyed
a very long working relationship with
this legislation enables us to provide
another
important tool for new hampshire
residents i'm happy to take any
questions the committee might have
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative talersky
thank you thank you for taking my
question can you just um give us a
little information on um how your
uh company deals with um the security i
know that there's some always has been
some concerns with online testing
platform sure um how you deal with that
sure so one of the ways we are extremely
concerned with it and we're always
looking for ways to improve the the
security of our of our testing products
so one of the things we've done is we
piloted a program
and we tested it with two of our
products one in california one in
florida we did a project last year with
those two states
and did a verification system where
students went through and did
user verification they entered
their government-issued id at the
beginning of the testing project or at
the beginning of their
their test taking
at the start of the course and then
throughout the course that was verified
that they were the same person taking
the test so if i enter my government
instead i'm stephen bristow that was
verified throughout the course that i
was the same person taking that course
until the end of the course
the court that project has proven so
successful that we've expanded it to all
of our projects or to all of our
and i'm sorry sir
representative woods representative
woods uh thank you i'm a substitute so
i'm
not known here very well uh just a quick
question uh thank you mr chair uh is
this a
innovative kind of uh
um
security procedure or is this sort of
more standardized along the lines
of when you take an online course like
my son-in-law just finished his mba
and they had a very distinct protocol
of verifying that he was in fact
taking the test and he was not getting
input from anybody else
is that sort of a standard for the all
the universities use or is this
something that's very peculiar
and uh sort of another level of security
well we're not a university sir but it
is privately becoming
a
standardized for anybody that's doing
any type of online education product
thank you
any further questions
representative
and i'm sorry fellows oh thank you mr
chairman can can you just explain what
that verification process is how how is
it that you know
exactly who it is that's
attending each lesson of the class and
exactly who it is
that's taking the online test
sure and i will apologize because techn
the technology is not my forte my
understanding of the way the process
works is that
i would submit
my driver's license or a government
issued id
at the beginning of the process and then
that is verified against
the i i submit my id and then a picture
is taken at various points
and
at as i take the
the
test or as i take the course
and the two are compared so that if
the two pictures don't match up
the uh
uh
it's flagged and
that
the uh technology is sent back and
a uh
an incident is flagged and then
we can review it at that point and say
okay this incident shows that you had
two people that don't match up
and
at that point you can say okay we have
any further questions from the committee
carol
thank you mr chair could you tell me um
you're talking about pictures being
taken are those pictures held or are
they uh do you you know
they're just
again i'm
i i'm not the technology person my
understanding is that they are destroyed
immediately after the person is done
with the course the user consents to
using them and those are being done as
soon as they're done with the course
they're destroyed
that's my understanding again i'm not
thank you
any further questions from the committee
representative
thank you mr chair
excuse me
thank you for taking the question
is there anything in the technology that
you use to verify the individual
there's nothing to prevent that
individual from
that's taking the course and the
ultimately the exam from having somebody
coach them in the room with them to help
them
you know give them the answer so to
speak
again i think that
it depends on how sensitive you set the
the uh
parameters
you can set it to to
as sensitive as
if i know
if i notice that you look away for a
specific period of time or if there's
too much movement away from the monitor
seeing none thank you very much i
i usually say them for the end but i
think in this case uh the chair
recognizes
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i'm rick bailey i'm the
assistant commissioner at the department
of safety
i will be brief but happy to answer
questions
the
amendment that was brought forward in
the senate that's part of the bill now
that deals with how the entry-level
driver training program will work here
in new hampshire
there was a very unusual portion of the
federal law that deferred to state law
in new hampshire we've only contemplated
driver education for 16 and 17 year olds
because once you become 18 all you have
to do is pass the test you do not have
any prerequisite of a formal training
the entry level driver training program
at the federal level is in fact a driver
education program that's spelled out
very clearly in
federal law and rules that is a
full-blown how to drive a cdl all the
things you need to consider
the challenge that came up was because
we had never contemplated
advanced driver training if you will it
wasn't clear in the legal review as to
whether all the requirements that we
have for driver ed instructors who are
teaching 16 and 17 year olds
would all of a sudden become
applicable to people that are providing
the entry-level driver training program
um and so we took the two steps that mr
abbott talked about we asked for a
waiver uh from the federal government to
waive the portion of the law that says
they defer to state requirements
so that we had an opportunity to bring
before you this requirement to make it
clear that people who are compliant with
the federal program
have no additional requirements placed
on that instruction either but for the
course or the instructor
by new hampshire state law or rule and
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative sykes
thank you chairman walsh
uh assistant commissioner bailey i know
that um
in the recent past that i believe the
federal government has tried to
recognize a problem for cdl licensure
that if you were under if you were 18
but not 21 you could only drive
cdl in your state
and is that still the case yes but
that's under consideration it's in
discussions at the federal motor carrier
safety administration as to whether
they're going to
lower from 21 perhaps to 18 or something
in between because of the substantial
shortage of long-haul truck drivers so
this does not follow up
so so
i just want to make sure so this is not
fixing that problem yet
no and even but there's an effort to to
there's a separate effort to deal with
that problem but this training
requirement would apply to anybody if if
they do lower the age they would those
applicants would still have to go
through this training program
so this doesn't create another conflict
down the road if they change the age
requirement no it doesn't okay thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you mr chair good to see you it's
been a while
are you comfortable asking a question
about the boater portion of this
uh
lieutenant mclean is here i can give it
a try we'll see where we go all right is
he coming up or jeez
you can come on crystal
oh it's an easy one so
no
so in in reading the uh the proposed
amendments of the language
it looks to me like it doesn't change
the nature of the test at all it's still
a proctored examination the only change
is
who can administer it so is it correct
the
even if this passes the test is still
going to be administered under
supervised conditions
you're just allowed to have somebody
else do it
good afternoon my name is crystal mclean
for the record and i'm with state police
marine patrol that is correct that it
will still be a
a proctored exam
it's it's more of a housekeeping issue
for the language of the law and we have
we have sought legal counsel and uh it
is more of a housekeeping item as
proposed for the boating part of it
any further questions from the committee
representative talersky thank you mr
chairman
lieutenant can you just confirm what i
think i heard in the previous testimony
that already we have an online training
and testing program for snowmobiles
ohrvs
and are those programs successful
i can confirm the boating portion of
that i
can't speak to the snowmobile and the
ohrv where fish and game houses that
typically
i could defer to the kalkamai
representative
further questions
cnn thank you both very much thank you
sorry representative fellows
thank you mr chair since i'm a
substitute i'm not up to speed
as much as the other people here
but is is it the case that somebody can
get a boating license by taking a test
but they don't ever have to get into a
boat
currently the way the law is written
they anybody that's going to operate a
boat that has an engine with greater
than 25 horsepower has to have safe
boating education there's a couple of
methods that they can take to comply
with that law
both in state and federally
if it's
over that they do need to have that
voting education certificate currently
there is no practical requirement
thank you
any other questions
uh chair recognizes jody gambrellis from
new hampshire marine trades association
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is jody
grimbolus i'm the lobbyist for the new
hampshire marine trades association that
is the new hampshire group of small
businesses that work in the marine
industry and really focus on
recreational boating
we're here in support of senate bill
307 and specifically
can talk to the beginning of the the
first section of the bill
we see this as a very positive
step forward for boater safety education
having that ability to do that proctored
test online would be a great innovation
for new hampshire
it's more convenient for the boaters
and quite honestly it makes them take
the new hampshire test and not the
florida test which is also accepted here
so we'd rather see new hampshire boaters
people boating in new hampshire on
vacation take the new hampshire test
which is specific to new hampshire laws
then take it from another state where
they can do it all online and then come
here we have different safe passage laws
than other states we have different
you know different buoy systems than
other states and we'd really like them
to take the entire test with the new
hampshire information we also think it's
a benefit because then new hampshire
keeps those dollars so if they're going
to spend money on the boater education
do it in new hampshire not florida so i
hope that's helpful
try to answer any questions i can but
from a practical perspective the marinas
that see renters or new boaters think
the new hampshire test is the one to
take and if this helps do that then
we're all for it
thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
cnn thanks again
last person i have signed up to speak
jason stock timberland owners
association
well good afternoon my name is jason
stock i'm the executive director of the
new hampshire timberland owners
association
and we represent the state's forest
landowners forest products industry
and like gary abbott our interest in the
bill is the cdl portion of the the bill
sections two through i think it's
sections two through five
our members run a lot of trucks they
they ship logs from the forest to the
sawmills
and then they ship lumber from the
sawmills to the home depots of the world
and so
like every other industry
everyone's scrambling for truck drivers
and and having
this bill will help
as you heard earlier with some of the
training requirements get us in
alignment with the federal requirements
as they're getting rolled out and so
we're fully in support of it the other
it's not watering down any of the
training requirements it's not going to
create unsafe conditions out there on
the roads it brings us into alignment
with the federal standards and we
believe that overall this will help
kind of streamline the process and
hopefully we can get more young men and
women
licensed and on the road driving our
logs and lumber with that i'll conclude
my testimony and again
appreciate your support for this piece
of legislation
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
seeing them thanks again thank you uh
it's the last person to have signed up
to speak is there anybody else here that
wishes to do so
okay if you uh don't want to speak we
still do have the blue sheet out back
you can sign in your position for or
against with that i'm going to close the
we will be executing this bill as well
today and i know we've got i think four
or five more left from our executive
sessions this morning
uh we are in recess with it i do want to
check on the status of a couple of
amendments as soon as i have that status
um i'm going to open up the executive
session we're going to backtrack a
little bit on uh house bill 1401
if anybody's wondering i did open up the
executive session on 1463 and then put
it in recess it still is in recess i
just wanted to get caught up on the ones
that were ahead of it
that being said the chair recognizes
representative gorsky for a motion
thank you mr chairman i'd like to make a
motion
for otp on h bill house bill 1401
motions ought to pass is there a second
seconded by representative gagne uh this
bill is open to further amendment i
recognize representative gorski for
further motion
i think i will speak for representative
gorski
okay
i would like to
offer
amendment two zero two two zero nine
zero five h
um
uh amendment zero nine zero five h has
representative ankerberg would you care
to speak to your motion on the amendment
uh not particularly but it is a uh
it is simply just a a
quick um
sentence or two that was added um simply
to handle that situation where
uh alicia or renter was taking care of
uh
was the applicable person in here
it seems to be the the language that was
mentioned to us by the uh by the prime
okay thank you any other discussion from
the committee
on the amendment
so
i appreciate the changes that were made
but i i wonder and worry if it goes far
enough
um because there are additional
questions so
i
yeah the amendment doesn't quite go far
enough from my from my perspective
and uh
although it does answer part of the
questions
was there any attempt to wrestle with um
how to state people who didn't want to
you know
who
there was there was one other question
um i'm sorry i'm not quite prepared can
i get back
can i get back to you guys i do have a
question but i have to formulate it
okay any other questions from anybody in
i'll give a last call to representative
sykes
thank you for taking my question i did
want to know about we had a discussion i
think about the possible amendment uh
last time
in terms of addressing high efficiency
vehicles in terms of following the vin
number versus the person
um i didn't know if there'd been any
further discussion
with an eye towards that amendment i
mean i don't see it in here there may
have been some discussion
can you say that one more time in terms
of the issue uh we had talked about
whether there would be any
benefit to
clean the amendment effort to address
high efficiency vehicles specifically or
following the vin number as opposed to
the owner on the vehicle i guess it's
lessee a renter now also but
um i hadn't heard any further discussion
i'm not sure if it's needed or what the
amendment was pretty simple okay
in terms of just adding that third party
um
to enforce motor vehicle tax laws i
everything else should stay the same the
yep rebels
ask a question
motor vehicle sorry
line seven
public authority authorized to enforce
motor vehicle tax law so are we saying
that the other issues that came up in
terms of
um odometer tampering for resale or
title stuff or any of those other issues
that were raised with the department of
safety wouldn't fall under or state farm
also was opposed to it wouldn't fall
under this because those are not tax
issues
that's how i read it
basically all the other issues
this amendment the way i read it is
pretty simple all the other issues we
heard from the uh
from the title bureau et cetera et
cetera
they are not um
public authorities authorized in vehicle
tax laws so they wouldn't have
this bill has no impact on them that's
how i read it
representative fellows so we're
discussing the amendment correct
so
the only
seems to me
the only thing the only entity i can
think of
that they would not be able to share the
information with is the municipality
i am not sure
can you try to rephrase that because
at what point
the municipalities even require mileage
now
no motor vehicle no mileage information
shall be shared with any public entity
authorized to enforce motor vehicle
tax laws
so
but not on mileage
and so to to your point i think it
doesn't say that to your point i think i
agree with you as a public authority
authorizing the enforcement of motor
vehicle tax laws
with this amendment i would say
municipalities wouldn't get the mileage
unless consented by the owner or lessee
but i don't know of an instance where
municipalities currently look for
representative thompson
the municipalities make out the
applications for titles
uh which do require a mileage
declaration on them
so they have that information anyway at
go ahead
that's that's not a confirmation of they
don't go and check your
odometer to do it that's
you're writing that information on the
transfer paperwork right
so there still wouldn't be any transfer
of information that i can see well and
if there is it's actually done
voluntarily by the right because they're
from the owner they're filling out the
it's not a sharing correct
representative sykes
yeah thank you for
indulging me in the water i bought you
some time you did you did a good job
um
yeah so i
i see this as a problem because they
need that information
it doesn't it says you can't
give the information to the local towns
as it's currently written it doesn't say
why you can't give it to him it just
says you
can't and
it there's no explanation of it beyond
that it just says
use you know does tax
information
they can't have the information
but they do do other
they do need that for other purposes is
i think the keyword is shared so
and it's shared by the department or an
inspection station it says nothing about
whether the owner can share the
anybody else from the committee
i agree with that if you read the
language it's pretty clear it doesn't
doesn't prevent the owner or the or the
lessee or anybody else that
is going to share that information
it's not a department doing that or an
inspection station it's the owner
the leasee of the the vehicle that
shares that so i don't think it applies
to them in in the case of uh the mileage
that's done on a transfer on a title
it actually goes further and says
without the consent of the vehicle's
owner lisey or renter so
they would be consenting to do it if
they wanted it shared yep
anybody
else see nothing else we'll vote on the
amendment um
i can do it voice vote but with this
discussion why don't we call the roll on
it
yeah we can do that
all right so uh thank you thank you for
okay so adoption of amendment uh
2022-0905
h
okay so the amendment is adopted now the
motion on the floor is ought to pass as
amendment amended on house bill 1401
representative gorsky would you care to
speak to motion i do thank you mr
chairman
this particular bill
if passed is just going to protect our
new new hampshire citizens from from
being taxed there have been talks in the
federal government i have personally
heard secretary budejig talk about doing
this particular tax and i think with
everything that's going on right now
this bill will just create a small
firewall
to protect our new hampshire citizens
from
another unwarranted tax
so that's why i vote for otp of 1401
thank you sir any other comments
representative trojan thank you mr chair
is another note um it also helps the
consumer or the owner of the vehicle
from not having
that information then get go to the
insurance company which would then
probably set rates based on the mileage
driven so that's a kind of a byproduct
benefit
anybody else from the committee
representative sykes
so the part of this that i'm struggling
with is twofold
one is that this bill as it's currently
amended
would allow
would not allow a state vehicle vehicle
mile travel tax either
because they can't share the information
and yet there's efforts
bipartisan efforts in this house to
look at that the need for additional
revenues to maintain our roads and
bridges
which the
road toll continues to drop
every year of the amount of money that's
being collected so i have a little bit
of a problem
where this i believe this
prohibits the state from doing it as
well
on top of that
i understand um the point that the owner
lisi or renter
of the vehicle could consent to share
this information
but that smacks of
i joe citizen get to decide whether i
want to pay my taxes or not
and
i
that's a that's a whole separate
discussion and i don't know that we need
to be wading into that
that kind of discussion by creating law
representative tillerson
thank you i was um
representing sykes touched on what i was
going to say but
i just want to emphasize that with the
increased
efforts towards a more green future and
vehicles transitioning towards
better mileage and even fully on
electric vehicles that don't pay any
road gasoline tax through the road toll
we're in a really difficult position as
a state to figure out how we're going to
maintain our roads
there has already been a significant
drop
in revenue from the gas tax
due to just simply you know
honda crvs now getting 32 miles to the
gallon
never mind putting on full electric
vehicles on these roads and it is a
problem that as a state we are going to
have to figure out and this is
closing any opportunity we have
to address
the
road usage
as one of the factors we can at least
discuss and i think it is
uh inappropriate to
close that door before we even have a
chance to discuss it
so i will be voting against the ought to
this is why we have
these exercises this is why we do this
correct me if i'm wrong and i'll take
some help from anybody else reading this
thing when we heard
when we had the hearing
it was the understanding that this was a
firewall against
the federal attempt at an additional
mileage tax on us and i think we can all
agree to that
and it was also said at that time that
there was no intention by the prime
sponsor to
prevent the state of new hampshire from
implementing the same thing if we
decided to be fit
because we do have a problem i think we
can all understand that too
does this language prevent new hampshire
from doing it
i mean granted if we wanted to down the
road this could be reversed just as easy
um
but uh what say you
anybody
thank you mr chairman there there is an
issue with the mileage
fee that would be associated with the
the usage
regarding out-of-state vehicles coming
here um and how they that would be
implemented to them so somebody coming
from you know california driving out
here um you know so there there are
alternatives to mileage in terms of a
road usage fee um the primarily the at
least in terms of my perspective on that
the the biggest hurdle there is privacy
and not creating an intrusive
um
you know setting up waypoints and then
tracking people around with identifiable
data like that
but there are discussions of course this
is a a large issue um we all know we
need funding
but that this in my understanding that
this this amendment this bill
is intended to
protect the new hampshire taxpayer the
the new hampshire driver
vehicle owner operator
from having them be tracked
from the federal government right so if
we're worried about state issues i'm not
you know best by mileage
whereas we have other people using our
roadways
that are new hampshire citizens and also
none
the issue of what we do in the future is
another issue but point taken anybody
else in the community represents erosion
thank you mr chair and and again there's
a at the beginning of the paragraph
there there's a little closet
says notwithstanding any provision of
the law to the contrary so if down the
road we decided we wanted to
um tax electric vehicles by the mileage
driven
which
personally i'm not in favor of period i
mean there are other are other ways that
we can tax those vehicles um
that first part of the paragraph
gives a
a way to
do it if we decide at the state level we
want to tax that way
point taken
anybody else from the committee
representative sykes
so what the biggest concern that i can
see about this bill
is that it
takes or removes a tool that we as state
government probably have
to be able to fund
operations and every time you take away
a tool it then further restricts what we
are able to do
and makes it harder and you may end up
with something that you don't want
because you took away a tool
and that's my biggest objection to this
you're taking away a tool from state
government about how to raise funds to
pay for things
yes there
will be questions about how this gets
done
in the future but if you take the tool
away that we will never have those
discussions
no legislature can bind a future
legislature so there would be
we may be taking that tool away to use
your your term
but
that tool can always be put back into it
by a
simple repeal word um so i'm not sure i
would say this will never happen
but i don't know why um
i
i don't understand the
thought process um to say that
this is removing the tool other than for
what the prime sponsor suggested that it
it creates that firewall from
any kind of federal
licensor
okay
one representative sykes so thank you
representative hill um
i i would only observe
in my
and i'm a newbie i've only this is i've
only been doing this for 10 years
um
i would only observe that repealing laws
is more difficult than it is to pass
them
and so i just
throw that out there
i i think you have a valid point that we
could change it at some point but it is
a little more difficult by past
experience
anybody else
see
i would just make the point that this
this talks about tax laws when we talk
about the road toll there's there's a
difference between a usage fee
and a levied tax
you know and one is unconstitutional and
the other one is
you know
allowable
right so this talks about tax laws
so when we talk about a usage fee
you know that i'm not even sure that
that would necessarily apply in
something like this like under this
that's unclear as well another good
point and let's hope the federal
government's not watching and they call
theirs a fee instead
[Music]
seeing nobody else i'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role as soon as she's
ready the motion on the floor is ought
vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes
representative boyd yes representative
torrenson yes representative sykes
no representative fellows no
representative fenton no representative
of rambo no representative rich no
representative celersky no
representative fox no representative
stevens no representative woods no
ten to nine
all right the committee uh
committee recommendation about the pass
as amended has adopted ten nine
uh did i hear you make a motion for
i guess not
well if you heard it
regular calendar it goes uh we'll be
taking up house bill 15 34 give us a few
minutes
just just let the vice chair know when
you know
[Applause]
did you see the amendment for this
no but i don't have the amendment for
the last one
is a really bad amendment
[Laughter]
can i i need a i'd like a
because i i don't have one larry swears
he gave it to me
i'm sure he did but i don't i can't
probably under here
well
i have a curious question
tom
do you know if this is going to finance
yeah
yeah i mean in fairness yeah
well and actually because we're past the
deadline for second committee bills
if they deem it to be such i wonder what
happens there i don't know that would be
a shame thanks larry
all right i'm going to open up the
executive session on house bill 1534
and this is relative to
you
authorizing the use of side exhaust for
antique vehicles something a little
later topic
uh chair recognizes representative
crawford for a motion
i'd like to make a motion to adopt
amendment
no just just otp oh oh yeah ought to
pass on amendment two zero two i can't
even do that we'll do about the pass and
i'll introduce the amendment no no
house bill house bill house bill
15 34.
so the motion on the floor is ought to
pass on house bill 1534 is their second
representative gagne second sentence
okay this bill's open for further
amendments
go ahead i'll speak to it if you want to
offer it okay anything you want to do
so representative hill yes um i would
h and 2022-0908-h the chairman speak to
it okay uh is there a second
one
second invite representative crawford
thank you okay this is the long awaited
for amendment house bill 1534. as you
remember from the public hearing
department of safety had an issue the
way the original language
if somebody with a four-door antique
wanted to run such side exhausts
so i did get a series of amendments
finally this one shows
that it will be to the rear edge of
either door if it has two doors into the
rear edge of either rear door if the
vehicle has four doors
uh any such system shall direct exhaust
away from the vehicle
so
it's pretty self-explanatory and i
believe uh i hope the department of
safety is okay with it too i see a head
shaking back there
uh anybody else wish to speak to the
amendment
seeing none uh all those in favor of the
adoption of amendment zero nine zero
eight h
signify by saying aye aye opposed nay
okay so the amendment is adopted motion
on the floor is now ought to pass as
amended
uh
no you know what i'll fight me up you
can you can revert to me if you will
i'll speak to it if you will okay okay
okay
she made the motion is out to pass
as amended by the adoption of the
amendment that's on the floor
i'm just going to speak to it briefly
i don't think there's much else to say
other than that pretty much is the bill
um please make a lot of antique
enthusiasts happy i hope you do support
this
anybody else from the committee
seeing none i'll ask the chair to call
the role as soon as she's ready on the
motion on the floor promoting me again i
mean uh the clerk ought to pass as
amended been a long day on 1534 it's
okay
representative smith
yes burke both yes representative hill
yes representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
representative trojan votes yes is that
what i've been saying
thank you for the correction
representative sykes yes
representative fellows yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo yes representative rich yes
representative tillerson
yes president fox yes representative
stevens yes representative woods yes
chairman walsh
yes
19-0 19-0 uh committee recommendation
about to pass as amended it's adopted
19-0 i heard a motion for consent who
was that
representative thompson second
with no objection consent that is i'm
going to close the executive session on
house bill 15 34.
a couple of minutes we'll be moving
right in no sense stopping now we're
having the time of our lives
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1463 relative to
driver's license issued in accordance
with the real id act of 2005.
chair recognizes representative hill for
a motion
thank you mr chairman i would move
in expedient to legislate
motion is itl is there a second
second by representative thompson do you
wish to speak to motion
uh certainly um
no problem
um
my computer is not
functional but i will tell you that i
think there's a number of things
that i object on this legislation
one of which is if you
if you go through part b
all the way down with the num i think it
was the end of page two
and it says
the people that are
that this applies to it seems like there
should be
and or or listed after each one of those
people
it seems impossible for you for someone
to be
all of those but
it lists
it lists one section after another and
i'm not sure that is how
it was originally designed to be written
but that's how it comes off that's
that's one problem i have
um it also seems to be this is the thing
that creates
essentially
a super passport for um
for someone that uh i think if you look
at number seven or number eight
that has uh pending or approved
applications for temporary protected
status
there's nothing in the bill that says
what happens
if
the
application is denied
does the
does the real id terminate at that point
don't know
nothing in here
specifies whether
or an actual road test is required for
any of these
or whether insurance is required for any
of the people
nothing
nothing in the bill
tell us the full story as far as i can
see
and yet we would be giving essentially
a passport that can be used for any
number of
of items
whether it's opening a bank account
whether it's
voting
whether it's um
traveling across the country all of
those things are possible
with this real id and
so for those reasons and many others
i would suggest
itl on this bill
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
representative did you have your hand up
yeah thank you mr chair
yes and and i did fill in on the
committee the day we heard this
testimony in this bill and and i recall
testimony that
indicated that um
if we were to pass this legislation it
would violate the current real id
um
you know provisions of that law
currently so that would be problematic
representative tallerski
thank you mr chairman
i wanted to point something out that i
don't think
we actually
uh got as much information on that um
there are already people who are not
citizens who have valid new hampshire
driver's licenses i went back
last year
march 2021 i reached out to director
bilecki to get some
numbers on how many non-citizens
have driver's licenses these are
people who are here legally on green
cards
maybe working
in different fields have come over to
help with our
shortage of employees and skilled
workers
and as of last year march of 2021
we had 25
driver's licenses
that
were issued to
non-citizens who are temporary residents
non-driver id cards that were given to
non-citizens of our state that's 29 000
people who are already carrying driver's
licenses
i've heard of no evidence
of people
who are here with driver's licenses who
are not citizens
accessing benefits that they're not
supposed to get
registering to vote
when they shouldn't be
we have almost thirty thousand people
who already have driver's licenses here
who are not citizens
so when the real id requirements go into
effect
for entering federal buildings for
flying for any of those things we have
thirty thousand people who aren't going
to be able to get
the driver's license that will allow
them
to participate in those activities
in our country
so i think just think that didn't come
out in the in the testimony and i want
to make sure you all understand
there are non-citizens who have driver's
you representative sex
and the the final point that i would
like to make is that
during the public hearing there was some
testimony on the part of the dmv
where
there was
later admitted to i heard the person
from the dmv and the citizens group who
was most interested in this bill
the two of them acknowledged that he was
in error about some of his testimony and
that
this
the bill as written is just trying to
bring us into compliance full compliance
rather than an exception
compliance
with the real id act that the fed
federal government has written and the
reason and the biggest difference is the
20 29 000 people that you just heard
about this is trying to make it possible
for those 29 000 people to get the real
id that they are
otherwise in
other states qualified to get and they
are again to repeat they're here legally
they're working here
they have a driver's license but they
can't get the federal id
part real id portion of it
because of an exception that was granted
to new hampshire this is just trying to
fix
um i heard representative crawford first
i don't know if anyone from dmv dmv is
here but of the 29 000
licenses that are issued are those from
visas that are temporary or those actual
driver's licenses that for people who
[Music]
are if they're only here temporarily are
those just temporary
licenses without dragging her without
her coming up well she can if you'd like
to but as far as i remember just you can
shake ahead if i'm wrong as far as i
recollect through discussions in the
past anybody with a current green card
or work visa
can get a new hampshire driver's license
temporarily it expires when their visa
or green card does that's right
thank you mr chair
so these are the requirements from the
department of homeland security the
united states department of homeland
security
on december 27
the
real id modernization act became
effective and i think this was largely
misunderstood this removed the
requirement that a separate social
security
document be collected did not remove the
requirement that a social security
number
be collected
to uh in order to issue a real id
compliant license or identification card
and i guess just to nail that home
under the paragraph explaining that
homeland security has provided a big
giant does an applicant still need to
provide their social security number
when applying for a real id
yes both the real id act and the new
regulation require states to collect and
retain an individual social security
account number during the application
process so nsco can remove that
requirement and still have real id
thank you representative
any further discussion rep
representative sykes
yeah
representative smith thank you for that
could you
i
i of all days for me to leave my
paperwork at home today was the day i
left my paperwork at home can you point
out to me in the bill that is before us
where it says
you don't have to provide a social
security number
just help me i'll find it so i can
more correctly answer the your your
point
previously it said provides documents
required
required to demonstrate identity united
states citizenship social security
number and new hampshire residency
social security numbers stricken out
so it's i guess it's no longer a
well they're looking anybody else from
i do have a question
sure
i know that um
some of these 29 000 people can in fact
get their social security number
if the language were changed by an
amendment would that be something that
would change anybody's mind
because i i acknowledge the there's an
error there that shouldn't
we're not trying to
go
away from
federal requirements we're trying to
match federal requirements
and
we did ask for a further opinion from
the dmv but they they didn't get back to
us in time for this hearing
so i'm asking the indulgence of the
committee
to i could
basically ask for a straw poll right if
i take that out we fix that with an
amendment which
admittedly will take some time will it
change anybody's mind and if it won't i
i'm just trying to work with you guys
right
i was hoping to get everything done
today catching me off guard with that
but even if we were to change that error
we keep talking about the 29 000 people
um
say that was fixed it would still be
eligible or the difference of the 29 000
if some of them could get a social
security number
can but there's still a lot of people
what scares me the most about this
is the pending the word pending
anybody can come to this country and
claim asylum anybody can come to this
country and claim temporary protective
status
those are the ones
even with a temporary license are still
being reviewed and i don't know that we
should be giving anybody that's under
review for a claim of something until
it's done a driver's license that looks
like everybody else's so i still have an
issue with it there i'll let anybody
else on the committee continue or voice
their opinion
anybody else from the committee
representative hill
thank you mr chairman i in addition to
that pending um
or approved application section
i still have a problem knowing what
happens if
if that application is rejected
does that mean you still have
someone that's able to drive until the
temporary tag is removed is it
immediately um
invalid
and i still haven't heard answers to
whether
you know we just had a bill on driver ed
that
made people apoplectic and i don't know
why
that wouldn't be included in
this legislation if the idea was to just
get to the 29
000 people one of which is my 97 year
old mother um it would
it would be
a different bill entirely
so if what
the representative is suggesting is
rewriting the entire bill and just
dealing with those 29 000 that's a whole
different story and we're starting all
over again so
i'm of the opinion that this is not the
bill for those 29 000 but this bill has
more problems with it than we can solve
anybody else
uh and i also have to look at our
deadlines uh again this was the day for
us to finish um
with all respect representative sykes i
really did want to finish up today
with nothing anybody else for the
committee
seeing none
the motion on the floor
excuse me a motion on the floor in house
bill 1463 is inexpedient to legislate
allows the clerk to call the roll when
vice chairman cagney
yes representative smith
yes
kirk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes
representative trojan yes
representative sykes
no representative fellows no
representative fenton
representative rambo
no representative rich no representative
talarsky no representative fox no
representative stevens no representative
woods no chairman walsh
yes
all right the committee recommendation
of itl has adopted 10-9 i'm going to
close the executive session on house
bill 1463
uh next up give us a couple of minutes
uh one six six six i don't think so
because it has a floor i acknowledge the
floor we don't have the chance to fix it
is
is it going to be a minority report no
that's what yeah
the question was if there would be a
minority report which was asked of us
my answer is that
no there won't be a minority report um
it can't go on consent obviously because
of the
um i'm not putting we're not going to
put it in a minority report because i
it's unfortunate that we only learned
about it at the last possible second
but be that as it may um it still needs
to be fixed so that we won't argue it
on the floor with a minority report
fair enough we may argue
we may argue it
on the floor i should say but we're not
going to bother with the minority report
say that again we may in fact have you
know flight a flight
we're talking about flights here for
people
we may fight it on the floor but we're
not going to
bother with the minority report
[Music]
all right i'm going to open the
executive session on house bill 1666
relative to the application process for
driver's licenses and the privacy of
motor vehicle records chair recognizes
representative gorsky for a motion
thank you mr chairman i like to make a
motion of itl on 1666.
is there a second
seconded by representative thompson
would you wish to speak to your motion
yes i do thank you mr chairman
this bill
really focuses on our undocumented
people and
my
i have several concerns with this bill
number one
prohibiting the sharing of information
to federal immigration enforcement if in
fact it has found that someone
is not here legally
what this does if we give them license
it makes this makes a license a legal
document for them
in essence
will make new hampshire a sanctuary
state
and
quite frankly
you know when we look at driver's
license driver's licenses is a privilege
not a right
for these reasons i vote itl for this
bill
anybody else
any further discussion
representative sykes
thank you mr chairman
so
i want to talk about what this bill does
do and what it does not do
so the first thing is
um
the the passage of this bill as it's
written
would remove
what i call an unnecessary burden of law
enforcement and the criminal justice
system for the state this is a federal
immigration problem that the federal
government should be dealing with
and so
interposing state
into this into this
equation
is uh to my mind a bit of a problem and
i think it's also very important that
people realize that
if a person comes here and they have no
documentation
it is a violation
it's not a criminal matter it's a civil
matter
and so there should be a separation of
these things
secondly
and more importantly
what we're really trying to do with this
i've heard from
folks
in this room today how important it is
that people get their driver's licenses
after testing
after after passing a written test and
passing a
driver's test and i absolutely agree
with that
and this would make possible for the
fifteen thousand people who are here
undocumented again a civil violation it
would make it possible for them
to
take that test
be proven to be
good
safe drivers
the other part of this is that local
police departments
almost all of them are engaged in an
effort
to improve their community relations to
get better policing models in place
and then be able to talk to the people
who live in their neighborhoods
when you don't have a driver's license
that one really big important way that
people can talk to their police
departments is when they as when they've
seen them out
having a driver's license so that if
they asked who they are they can prove
who they are
and they can prove where they live
and they can talk to police departments
is an important goal for public policy
public policy for safety sake public
support within the law enforcement
community for and also for them to make
open roads for them so they can talk to
all the people and who live in their
communities
it will
furthermore
allow
for the
to positively identify the driver
and that's an important
that's one of the most important points
of getting a driver's license with that
privilege to drive is it also identifies
who that person is
it's effective for regulation of motor
vehicle
operators
clearly it's safer i think we all agree
that if you take a test
written and practical and prove that you
can drive
is that's an important thing
it also allows people who are currently
driving let's make no mistake there are
people driving in this state who do not
have a driver's license
it makes it possible for them to get
insurance as well which is good for
everybody
it's good for business it's good for the
motoring public it's good for you if you
get involved in a a crash with somebody
who doesn't have a driver's license and
they flee that's
just
a bad thing and we can take away a lot
of these problems
this is a law that's effective this is a
law that
the like of which is effective in 17
other states
and that's all
happened quite recently
and of those 17 states some of them are
for example most recently massachusetts
did so because of the strong support of
the law enforcement community
vermont
new york
connecticut
they all have similar laws
allowing undocumented individuals to
be
shown and proven to be
safe
and again i just want to remind you
again being undocumented is not a
criminal matter it's a civil matter
but when they drive and don't have a
driver's license under our current law
it is a criminal matter not a civil
matter
so i'm just trying to take away some of
these problems
make
more fully integrated into the community
and leave the immigration law problem to
the feds where it most proper
further thoughts from the committee
representative hill
thank you mr chairman mr chairman
there's still the same issue that we ran
with the real id driver's license that
section is in here saying that
an applicant for a driver's license who
has not previously been licensed to
drive a motor vehicle in this state
shall provide his or her social security
number in the application if applying
for a real id driver's license
if the applicant is applying for a
non-real id then he or she may opt out
of social security not really sure it's
the same problem but we still have real
id mentioned in this bill as as one of
the problems
this this seems always to have been
getting around or ignoring
federal law and and that seems to be um
my problem with it more than anything
else um
it it seems to say
those people that you would like to get
the driver's license
it doesn't say in here that they that
they are required to take drivers tests
or
i didn't i didn't see that i may be
wrong um
but i also think that there is a it it
talks about
what information is needed to get the
driver to get the the license um i
didn't see that it would be that they
would be taking the driver's exam
um and i also didn't i i
never fully understood and it wasn't
brought up in testimony
but we did have people testifying here
that needed an interpreter
and and i'm wondering i've never
understood how we were able to get by
drivers um um
signs
i i have an australian mom who has no
idea what some of these signs are saying
um quite frankly so i'm not sure how
that works but the part of getting
around the federal laws is the part that
representative sykes
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative hill for the points that
you're making um
first things first
i've driven in probably
14 different countries
and i don't speak 14 different languages
i do speak three
but i've driven in places where i do not
necessarily
speak
or read or write the language but can
still drive quite safely and probably
could have hadn't tried to but you
probably could pass the test i think
that's you know really happens
much more frequently than and people
realize secondly
there's nothing mentioned in here about
the driving license test because
it's not in the part of the bill that of
the laws that we're amending the the
requirement for taking the driver's test
both written and practical is elsewhere
where this fits in
i
immigration problems
well let me let me rephrase it this way
i believe
that
it is incumbent upon this state
legislature to deal with those problems
for which we are able to deal with
now there are some constitutionally
which we can't take up
more appropriately the federal
government's responsibility
where it is a state responsibility and
driver licensure is strictly a state
responsibility
it should be the kind of questions that
we answer
and we answer those to make
our citizens in this state
as well as people who are just visiting
or living here
safer
the end of the day that's what this is
about this is about public safety making
it safer for people it's not an
immigration
it's not there's no attempt here to
you mentioned this bill will make the
road safer
you may be right because for an hour we
listened in our public hearing that in
spite of the fact uh that they may be
here illegally
they came to this country and they have
every right to
uh in spite of the law and they are
currently driving
in spite of the law and it's up to us
now to change that
i i disagree with with the with the
whole premise
um
so
you're saying the roads are more
dangerous because the people that are
not supposed to be here who are driving
on the roads are driving anyway
thank you for that anybody else from the
committee
representative thompson
and i i'm not sure who i address the
question too if it's
representative sykes or the chairman but
um
if
these people are undocumented and by all
admissions i guess they are
how do we even know who they are to
apply let them apply for a driver's
license
how is that verified if they don't have
a passport
uh
some of the birth certificates some
other
certification of who they actually are
why would we want to give them a
driver's license and what would the
purpose be
if those
names are not factual
i can answer that mr chairman if it's
allowable
thank you for the question
representatives
within this bill
there's a list of documents that will
achieve the following purposes
that we need to see in a driver's
license they will prove one
that they are of a proper age to drive
two that they are who they are that the
person standing in front of the dmv
clerk
is that person
and three it will prove that they
reside
in the state of new hampshire
and
those three things are what driver's
licenses are supposed to do they're
supposed to prove age
residency
and i lost my the third one there but i
you you hear my point it's built into
the law representative
it'll achieve all of those things that
you would like to see achieved
representative crawford
is there anyone
on this committee who was here i think
before covid
that remembers um
director burlecki testifying on a bill
that is very similar to this
if not almost the same bill yeah
actually i
i could answer them too
two ways
thank you representative crawford for
that question because it reminds me of
something a point that i forgot to make
it is true that two years ago
director bolecki raised some objections
to portions of the bill that i had
introduced at that point
they were corrected to the best of our
ability within this bill
and it is of interest to me and i'm not
if you might remember during public
testimony for this this bill
the dmv had no
testimony to give
um i i don't want to speak to their
motives because that's unfair
but i think it is telling that they did
not have any objections this time
they did not say they supported it
either so i believe we made some
important corrections
to
final thoughts
seeing none
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role as soon as she's ready the motion
vice chairman gagne
yes
representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes
representative boyd yes representative
trojan yes representative sykes
no representative fellows no
representative fenton
representative rambo no representative
rich no representative talersky no
representative fox no representative
stevens no representative woods no
chairman walsh yes
10 to 9.
committee recommendation of itl is
adopted 10-9
i'm going to close the executive session
on
house bill 1666 this is obviously going
yeah he did a minority report
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session
on house bill 1093
relative to the licensure of
non-resident aliens temporarily residing
in new hampshire
uh chair recognizes representative hill
for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move itl on
house bill 1093.
do i have a second reps second about
representative
gagne do you care to speak to motion
sure
um
i wrote this one down so driver's
licenses and ids cards are useful to
create an appearance
of lawful presence and serve as the
virtual passport to the nation
opening many doors that would otherwise
be unavailable
granting a driver's license or an id
card to those here illegally treats them
as they are lawfully present
in the united states and facilitates
further illegal conduct i believe it is
bad public policy and undermines the
purposes and objectives of federal
immigration law and for these reasons i
suggest
we vote itl
thank you representative further
discussion
representative tolerski
thank you mr chairman mr representative
sykes who's going to point this out but
this bill actually is about people who
are here legally
uh it's it's the section license for
aliens temporarily residing in new
hampshire this is
it
and they're here legally with a pending
application i just wanted to point out
they're not here illegally they're here
with a pending application and i will
then defer to represent psych sorry
representative sykes
thank you mr chairman
so
this was a bill that
actually former dmv director belecki and
i
wrote together to try and fix a
technical
what we both viewed as a
as a flaw in the the dmv laws
the issue is this
a person who enters the united states
and enters so
as a legal
entry into this country
may have
a visa for instance one example is a
tourist visa they may come in on a
tourist visa but they're fleeing
violence in their country or some other
reason
drug warlords
civil war
real war
but they're here and they're here
legally
but they cannot drive because if you
have a
tourist visa you are prohibited under
new hampshire law from getting a
driver's license
however
once
a clock
starts
and under new hampshire law
if you have a work permit
you can then successfully apply for take
the written and
practical exam and get a driver's
license that's current law right now if
you get a work permit you can take your
driver's test and get a driver's license
the problem is and
is that
the federal system is such that it takes
forever literally
to get that
your asylum status resolved
the feds recognize this so what they do
is
if they have if you have not had your
pending asylum request hearing
after
365 days after one year you can then
apply for and receive
a work permit
and then in turn once you have the work
permit you can apply for and receive
with testing a new hampshire driver's
license all of that exists now
the time frame when they're living here
in new hampshire they're here illegally
they are required to get a driver new
hampshire driver's license but they
cannot because they don't have the work
permit and the purpose of the bill is to
close the gap
between those and give a temporary
license
for the gap time
and then they would then come in and it
would it would expire
after
i think was a hundred and
180 days it would expire
but then they will have had time to have
gotten their work permit and test and
get their driver's license that way it's
just trying to fill that little gap
they're here legally
they get their driver's license the
driver's license that they get with
their work permit which many of these
are given out all the time they do have
an expiration
expire when the work permit expires
as a real world example for this and the
have a
person to me known to me
who
arrived on a
tourist visa legally
but was fleeing
gang violence where he had been
kidnapped
and was fortunately able to escape and
he brought his family out of that
country here to the united states
he applied for asylum
he did not get a driver's license until
he got his work permit which was a more
than a year later
he is still now
seven years later
still waiting
for his asylum request to be answered
and that's what we're trying to make
possible we're just trying to close that
little gap
between you arrive you ask for asylum
and you get your
work permit the work permit is automatic
they get it as soon as
the if the feds haven't given them their
hearing they get that work permit
automatic
so that's all i'm trying to do with this
bill it's pretty simple it had the
support of the dmv
former director we wrote it together so
we could close this small gap it's a
very narrow
any further questions or discussion from
the committee representative corrosion
thank you mr chair i guess it's one of a
question
because in in this proposed legislation
it
sounds like a temporary driver's license
for 180 days
in the example that the representative
just cited
he said
seven years later they still don't have
that asylum so
if this was to pass
my understanding correctly that they
would get a driver's license for 180
days and then the remaining several
years they wouldn't have one if if they
hadn't been the asylum hadn't been
approved well let me let me put it this
book thank you for the question um
representative
imagine there's two different drivers
licenses one is a temporary that only
lasts for the 180 days
the next one is
temporary but can last indefinitely
until the feds
that temporary driver's license
once you have a work permit is existing
law now
what doesn't exist is that little gap
between when you apply for asylum
and you get your work permit
automatically that's this is just about
seeing then
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
roll as soon as she's ready the motion
vice chairman gagne
yes
representative smith
mark votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative thorson yes
corrosion sorry
representative sykes
no
representative fellows no representative
fenton
representative rambo no representative
rich no representative talarsky
no representative stevens
no representative woods no chairman
committee recommendation of itl on 10
house bill 1093 is adopted uh regular
calendar
i'm going well first of all minority
report representative sykes there will
be one i'm going to try and farm it out
all right i'll close the executive
session on house bill 1093
we only have one left folks
give us a couple minutes senate bill
307.
10 to 9. yep but i'll take that one
already
absolutely
about
um
[Laughter]
i don't have anything to throw at you so
you know you can say whatever you want
you're good
[Music]
they've been trying to get rid of that
damn thing for years
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session
i'm going to hope you have the executive
session on senate bill 307
relative to the issuance of safe boater
education certificates and commercial
driving instruction chair recognizes
representative thompson for a motion
mr chairman i'd like to make a motion to
otp on 307. okay uh motion about the
pass is there is there a second
second by representative gorsky do we
uh yes um
mr chairman uh
i think the boating uh
part of this is uh
kind of a no-brainer the uh as far as
the commercial driver's licenses go
um i think anything we can do to
expedite uh
more driving more commercial drivers
licenses in the state and in the country
is probably the best we can do for
fair enough any other discussion on
senate bill 307
representative sykes
yeah i'd be in support of the otp i
think it's it's it's good that we get
our state law about motor vehicle
carrier licensing
um in line with the feds so there's no
thank you for that in this case i don't
think we have a choice but you are
correct
uh any other discussion
representative ankerberg i think it's
also you thank you mr chairman i think
it's also useful to note that
with all the with new hampshire
recognizing licenses currently
obtained from out of state through
recognized coast guard safety programs
that this may actually lead to a net
increase in revenue
um
you know due to
folks actually
taking one required um
new hampshire specific uh voter
information um and also with those fees
to be paid in state instead of uh being
sent to
places outside of here thank you
thank you sir anybody else
seeing then i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll as soon as she's ready uh the
motion is opt to pass and senate bill
vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith yes clerk folks yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson
yes representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
boyd yes representative
yes
representative sykes yes representative
fellows yes representative fenton yeah
representative rambo yes representative
rich yes representative talarsky yes
representative fox yes representative
stevens yes representative woods yes
chairman walsh yes
19-0 yeah
so the committee recommendation is
adopted 19-0 ought to pass
consent's been moved by representative
gagne i saw a second by representative
ankerberg
with no objections
that's where it'll go so i'm going to
close the exact session on senate bill
307.
i did my best um i want to thank
everybody uh this was a long day i know
um and i
do hope i can get all these committee
reports
before you leave actually i'm going to
have uh representative gagne
inventorium now
are you going to be able to give me both
okay yeah i'm not going anywhere for a
committees
so
um
see if you do owe me a report please do
get it in and i'll be around for a while
i'm going to review them all i'm going
to try to get all these turned in by the
end of today as well again thank you
very much
i'll see you on the 10th i don't know
how many of these will make it up on the
10th
uh because we're not facing any
deadlines
i'm sorry i just wanted to clarify that
um since we don't have any we don't have
any senate bills that have been passed
over to us we won't be meeting as a
committee potentially until
after crossover in april
that is correct we get senate bill 307
fast tracked because of the issues with
the federal government a lot of change
i don't expect to see any more until
after crossover so we are technically
on committee break yeah until after
crossover great i just wanted to confirm
yes sir thank you mr chairman uh i want
to thank you and the committee for
allowing
both of us substitutes to participate we
always learned something
and speaking of learning um
there was some
surprise visitors
uh to you and surprise visitors to me
as well
my daughter and two grandchildren
welcome will be uh
perhaps sitting here someday and they're
trying to learn the ropes well good so
thank you for being a very good example
uh hopefully they were a very good
example they were how they were well
it's a pleasure to have you in
transportation thank you mr chair and
nice meeting all of you if you do run
you